REPORTER: Could I ask you first,
your Royal Highness,
what was
your instant impression?
I remember thinking
what a very jolly, and amusing,
and-- and attractive 16-year-old
she was.
I don't know
what you thought of me, but...
-Pretty amazing. (CHUCKLES)
-(LAUGHS)
♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
SPEAKER: Sweet, kind...
SPEAKER 2: The princess has been
the best thing to happen
to the monarchy in centuries.
-REPORTER 2:
Did you get a chance to see her?
-CHILDREN: Yes!
SPEAKER 3: Diana is
very big news, everywhere.
SPEAKER 4:
She's got the common touch.
-♪ (SOMBER MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
-(CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING)
REPORTER 3: The prince realizes
that he's taking second place.
(LAUGHTER)
(BIG BEN CHIMES)
REPORTER 4:
A hollow and tormented marriage
are giving the British media
and its public
little else to talk about.
REPORTER 5:
Please give me one picture--
Out!
SPEAKER 5: She's been pushed
from the word go.
It's the media that's causing
the problems. Leave 'em alone.
-(CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING)
-REPORTER 6: Lady Diana.
(CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING)
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
SPEAKER 6:
She's been through the worst
that can be thrown at her.
(CAMERA SHUTTER CLICKING)
SPEAKER 7: I think we've got
an unhealthy obsession.
And I think she's very close
to being a monster.
-(FLAMES ROARING)
-SPEAKER 8: She has a sick mind.
She likes to be with people.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: She likes
to be bloody well watched!
-SPEAKER 9: That's ridiculous.
-SPEAKER 10:
She has been humiliated.
-(BIG BEN CHIMES)
-(CROWD CHEERING)
SPEAKER 11:
When you put a modern person
in an ancient institution,
-they will be destroyed.
-♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
SPEAKER 7:
The monarchy is in danger
of too much publicity.
SPEAKER 12: At what point
do the British people say,
-"I don't want to hear anymore"?
-(GLASS SHATTERING)
SPEAKER 13: What's wrong with us
as a country...
-(SCREAMING)
-SPEAKER 13: ...should this mean
so much to us?
(CHEERING)
SPEAKER 14:
They just can't sweep her
under the carpets.
(MÉLANGE OF SPEAKERS
TALKING ABOUT LADY DIANA)
(CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING)
(BIG BEN CHIMES, FADES)
PRINCE CHARLES:
At the other side,
then you'll see.
Look through there. You see--
You can see
looking on the side of this.
Look. Look, you see the faces?
(CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING)
PRINCE CHARLES:
The people in there...
look at them. (CHUCKLES)
Trapped.
♪ (SOMBER MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪